Ihr wisst alle: Unser Planet nur einer von
vielen.
Doch Astronomen-Teams weltweit diskutieren
schon seit einigen Jahrzehnten darüber, dass
nicht nur unsere Erde, sondern unser gesamtes
Universum unbedeutend ist - zumindest im kosmischen
Maßstab.
Demnach existieren neben unserem bekannten
expandierenden Universum noch unzählige Weitere.
Alle jeweils mit ihren eigenen Naturgesetzen
- und Achtung: Vielleicht sogar mit unseren
galaktischen Doppelgängern?!
Was genau können wir uns also unter so einem
sogenannten Multiversum vorstellen, ist dort
tatsächlich Leben möglich und können wir
seine Existenz irgendwann vielleicht sogar
einmal beweisen?
herzlich willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Science Videos.
Abonniert Clixoom - Nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts
Ein super spannender Themenvorschlag, der
da mal wieder von Euch kam - und zwar über
die Whats App Community.
Link dazu ist in der Videobeschreibung.
Die Idee, die Kosmologen bereits seit Jahrzehnten
diskutieren, kann kurz zusammen gefasst werden:
Demnach gibt es nicht nur unser Universum,
sondern viele weitere Universen.
Statt einem Kosmos existiert dieser These
zufolge also ein sogenanntes “Multiversum”.
Der US-Physiker Brian Greene nennt das die
“super-kopernikanische Revolution”, denn
demnach ist das Universum, das wir wahrnehmen,
mehr als unbedeutend.
Zumindest im kosmischen Maßstab.
Die Frage ist also: Endet das All und wenn
ja, wo genau?
Was schließt sich dem an?
Teams aus Astronomen und Astonominnen definieren
unseren kosmischen Horizont bei der optischen
Grenze von rund 42 Milliarden Lichtjahren.
Doch scheint es doch keinen Grund zu geben,
warum das All dort aufhören sollte.
Stattdessen sind sich Fachleute weitestgehend
einig, dass jenseits des Horizontes viele,
vielleicht unendlich viele, Bereiche liegen,
die dem uns sichtbaren Kosmos ähnlich sind.
In jedem dieser Bereiche war die Materie zwar
anfangs unterschiedlich verteilt, doch in
allen gelten dieselben Naturgesetze.
In der Fachsprache wird dieser Typ des Multiversums
als “Ebene 1” bezeichnet.
Doch das ist nur der Anfang.
Manche Experten und Expertinnen gehen davon
aus, dass es völlig unterschiedliche Universen
gibt, in denen nicht nur eine andere Physik
herrscht, sondern auch unterschiedlich viele
Raumdimensionen vorkommen.
Beispielsweise wären die Eigenschaften und
die Art der Elementarteilchen, die wir ja
eigentlich für unveränderlich halten, in
jeder Parallelwelt einzigartig.
Der Physiker Alexander Vilenkin aus Russland
beispielsweise glaubt an dieses “Ebene 2-Multiversum”.
Das seiner Ansicht nach übrigens von Organismen
nur so wimmeln soll.
Unendlich viele Personen leben dort, die genau
DEINEN Namen tragen und genau wie DU auch
jetzt dieses Video gucken… Demnach entstehen
immerzu neue Universen und ihr könnt es Euch
sicher schon fast denken: Das Konzept der
Einzigartigkeit unseres menschlichen Lebens
ist seiner Theorie zufolge totaler Bullshit.
Alexander Vilenkin und Co stützen sich auf
folgende Annahme: Demnach kann es zwar unendlich
viele Universen geben, doch ist die Anzahl
der möglichen Zustände der Atome und Elementarteilchen
begrenzt.
Und somit auch ihre Variationen.
Demnach ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit also, in
einem Paralleluniversum, dass Milliarden Lichtjahre
entfernt ist, seinen Doppelgänger anzutreffen
ziemlich groß.
Der Wissenschaftler schätzt die Distanz zu
unserem nächsten Doppelgänger auf 10 hoch
10 hoch 100 Lichtjahre.
Unvorstellbar!
Doch wie genau erklärt die Physik diese These
des Multiversums?
Zurückzuführen ist diese Idee auf das Standardmodell
der Kosmologie, nach der sich das All unmittelbar
nach seiner Entstehung ausgedehnt hat und
dies auch immer noch tut - in der Fachsprache
auch “Inflation” genannt.
Manche Regionen sind demnach früher zum Stillstand
gekommen als andere - sie haben sich quasi
wie Blasen in kochendem Wasser abgesondert
- bildlich gesprochen natürlich.
Und so wäre auch unser Universum nur eine
Blase neben vielen weiteren.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler Alan Guth: “In
einem Universum, das sich grenzenlos inflationär
ausdehnt, passiert alles, was überhaupt passieren
kann, und zwar unendlich oft."
Jedenfalls würden sich die verschiedenen
Universen gegenseitig beeinflussen.
Anfang des Jahres (2018) hatte ein Forschungsteam
aus Großbritannien mit einem Supercomputer
die Expansion unseres Universums simuliert.
Als das Modell dann der Realität entsprach,
veränderten die Fachleute eine Variable - und
zwar die Menge der Dunklen Energie.
Diese ließen sie gegen Null sinken und auf
die 100-fachen Werte unseres Universums ansteigen.
Beide Veränderungen aber beeinflussten die
Häufigkeit sowie die Art und Weise, wie sich
Sterne und Galaxien bilden, nur unwesentlich.
Mit diesem Ergebnis hatte niemand gerechnet.
Doch es macht die Multiversum-Theorie tatsächlich
ein bisschen wahrscheinlicher.
Und zwar nicht nur, dass Planeten und Galaxien
in anderen Universen existieren, sondern auch,
dass sich dort Leben gebildet hat.
Aber nicht nur die Inflationstheorie prophezeit
andere Universen; diese könnten auch nach
der Stringtheorie existieren.
Wir haben hier schon öfter darüber berichtet.
Laut dieser Theorie gibt es einfach gesagt
viel mehr als links und rechts, hoch und runter
und vorwärts und rückwärts.
Die String-Theorie besagt, dass es eben sehr
viel mehr Dimensionen gibt!
Ein weiterer Punkt der String-Theorie: Es
wird davon ausgegangen, dass Materie nicht
aus Atomen oder noch kleineren Teilchen besteht,
sondern eben aus „Strings“, die sich in
einer zehn-dimensionalen Raum-Zeit bewegen.
Vorzustellen wie Fäden oder Linien, die wie
die Saiten einer Gitarre schwingen.
Und der folgende Fact sprengt unsere Vorstellungskraft
noch einmal mehr: Denn einige Dimensionen
sollen quasi „eingerollt“ sein.
Also ein bißchen so, wie wenn man ein Foto
des Universum zusammenrollt.
Fest steht jedenfalls, dass wir wohl niemals
so weit gucken oder reisen können, um unsere
Doppelgänger in anderen Universen zu finden.
Und genau das ist die große Schwäche der
inflationären Urknalltheorie.
Dabei darf man dennoch nicht vergessen, dass
sie die Beobachtungen im Kosmos so gut zusammenfasst
wie keine andere Theorie bislang.
Und wir kommen ja all diesen Theorien immer
mehr auf die Spur.
Ständig gibt es neue Erkenntnisse.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert am besten auch den englischen
Kanal.
Dafür einfach hier drauf klicken.
Denn auch da gibt es immer mal wieder Videopremieren.
Und hier geht es weiter mit (dafür auch drauf
klicken): Will String Theory be proven soon?
- Does our Universe even exist?
Ich hoffe wir sehen uns auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned see you soon!